todavía Hay posibilidades de que los
demócratas obtengan mayoría en la cámara
de representantes
es posible todavía pero estamos
esperando los resultados entonces hay
como 20 roles que no han sido decididos
todavía pero pronto vamos a tener los
resultados pase muy empatado entonces
hay un siroplicanos ganan van a tener
mayoría muy estrecha y precisamente si
los republicanos ganan la cámara de
representantes que escenarios se
dibujaría para la administración biden
con un congreso eventualmente dividido
si crean algunas complicaciones
importantes es que ellos van a lanzar
varias investigaciones ya han dicho eso
dice que no sabe por qué Pero ellos
dicen que van a intentar ajustarlo pero
ellos no va en tucar tanto porque puede
ser bloqueado por el senado y entonces
no solo es algo político para polinizar
aún más el sistema Pero hay otras cosas
muy importantes que ellos pueden
bloquear por ejemplo
la asistencia para Ucrania vamos a ver
si ellos van a apoyarlo o no entonces
hay otras cosas así que son muy
importantes no sigue con la mayoría y
con la mayoría ya declarada demócrata en
el senado todavía es relevante de alguna
manera la segunda vuelta de Georgia
Sí por supuesto porque ellos tienen más
posibilidades no tienen que contar con
una persona como hemos tenido en los
últimos dos años que un senador que este
pues Virginia que es más conservador
Entonces siempre ha sido un debate con
él una
un intercambio difícil para que
la apoya a los otros demócratas entonces
tenía una persona más ayuda mucho a los
demócratas que devoción una cosa más que
el senado tiene poder de aprobar los
jueces entonces solo tener los 50 ahí
tener la mayoría ahí ayuda mucho a los
demócratas con estos segundos la segunda
parte del mandato de baile